Business generates those resources
when it makes a profit.
That profit is that small difference
between the price and the cost it takes to produce
whatever solution business has created
to whatever problem they're trying to solve.
But that profit is the magic.
Why? Because that profit allows whatever solution
we've created
to be infinitely scalable.
Because if we can make a profit,
we can do it for 10, 100, a million,
100 million, a billion.
The solution becomes self-sustaining.
That's what business does
when it makes a profit.
Now what does this all have to do
with social problems?
Well, one line of thinking is, let's take this profit
and redeploy it into social problems.
Business should give more.
Business should be more responsible.
And that's been the path that we've been on
in business.
But again, this path that we've been on
is not getting us where we need to go.
Now, I started out as a strategy professor,
and I'm still a strategy professor.
I'm proud of that.
But I've also, over the years,
worked more and more on social issues.
I've worked on healthcare, the environment,
economic development, reducing poverty,
and as I worked more and more in the social field,
I started seeing something
that had a profound impact on me
and my whole life, in a way.
The conventional wisdom in economics
and the view in business has historically been
that actually, there's a tradeoff
between social performance and economic performance.
The conventional wisdom has been
that business actually makes a profit
by causing a social problem.
The classic example is pollution.
If business pollutes, it makes more money
than if it tried to reduce that pollution.
Reducing pollution is expensive,
therefore businesses don't want to do it.
It's profitable to have an unsafe working environment.
It's too expensive to have a safe working environment,
therefore business makes more money
if they don't have a safe working environment.
That's been the conventional wisdom.
A lot of companies have fallen into that conventional wisdom.
They resisted environmental improvement.
They resisted workplace improvement.
That thinking has led to, I think,
much of the behavior
that we have come to criticize in business,
that I come to criticize in business.
But the more deeply I got into all these social issues,
one after another,
and actually, the more I tried to address them
myself, personally, in a few cases,
through nonprofits that I was involved with,
the more I found actually that the reality
is the opposite.
Business does not profit
from causing social problems,
actually not in any fundamental sense.
That's a very simplistic view.
The deeper we get into these issues,
the more we start to understand
that actually business profits
from solving from social problems.
That's where the real profit comes.
Let's take pollution.
We've learned today that actually
reducing pollution and emissions
is generating profit.
It saves money.
It makes the business more productive and efficient.
It doesn't waste resources.
Having a safer working environment actually,
and avoiding accidents,
it makes the business more profitable,
because it's a sign of good processes.
Accidents are expensive and costly.
Issue by issue by issue, we start to learn
that actually there's no trade-off
between social progress
and economic efficiency
in any fundamental sense.
Another issue is health.
I mean, what we've found is actually
health of employees is something
that business should treasure,
because that health allows those employees
to be more productive and come to work
and not be absent.
The deeper work, the new work, the new thinking
on the interface between business and social problems
is actually showing that there's a fundamental,
deep synergy,
particularly if you're not thinking in the very short run.
In the very short run, you can sometimes
fool yourself into thinking
that there's fundamentally opposing goals,
but in the long run, ultimately, we're learning
in field after field that this is simply not true.
So how could we tap into
the power of business
to address the fundamental problems
that we face?
Imagine if we could do that, because if we could do it,
we could scale.
We could tap into this enormous resource pool
and this organizational capacity.
And guess what? That's happening now, finally,
partly because of people like you
who have raised these issues now
for year after year and decade after decade.
We see organizations like Dow Chemical
leading the revolution away from trans fat
and saturated fat with innovative new products.
This is an example of Jain Irrigation.
This is a company that's brought drip irrigation technology
to thousands and millions of farmers,
reducing substantially the use of water.
We see companies like the Brazilian forestry company Fibria
that's figured out how to avoid
tearing down old growth forest
and using eucalyptus and getting much more yield
per hectare of pulp
and making much more paper than you could make
by cutting down those old trees.
You see companies like Cisco that are training
so far four million people in I.T. skills
to actually, yes, be responsible,
but help expand the opportunity
to disseminate I.T. technology
and grow the whole business.
There's a fundamental opportunity for business today
to impact and address these social problems,
and this opportunity
is the largest business opportunity
we see in business.
And the question is, how can we get business
thinking to adapt this issue of shared value?
This is what I call shared value:
addressing a social issue with a business model.
That's shared value.
Shared value is capitalism,
but it's a higher kind of capitalism.
It's capitalism as it was ultimately meant to be,
meeting important needs,
not incrementally competing for
trivial differences in product attributes
and market share.
Shared value is when we can create social value
and economic value simultaneously.
It's finding those opportunities
that will unleash the greatest possibility we have
to actually address these social problems
because we can scale.
We can address shared value at multiple levels.
It's real. It's happening.
But in order to get this solution working,
we have to now change how business sees itself,
and this is thankfully underway.
Businesses got trapped into the conventional wisdom
that they shouldn't worry about social problems,
that this was sort of something on the side,
that somebody else was doing it.
We're now seeing companies
embrace this idea.
But we also have to recognize business
is not going to do this as effectively
as if we have NGOs and government
working in partnership with business.
The new NGOs that are really moving the needle
are the ones that have found these partnerships,
that have found these ways to collaborate.
The governments that are making the most progress
are the governments that have found ways
to enable shared value in business
rather than see government as the only player
that has to call the shots.
And government has many ways in which it could impact
the willingness and the ability of companies
to compete in this way.
I think if we can get business seeing itself differently,
and if we can get others seeing business differently,
we can change the world.
I know it. I'm seeing it.
I'm feeling it.
Young people, I think,
my Harvard Business School students, are getting it.
If we can break down this sort of divide,
this unease, this tension,
this sense that we're not
fundamentally collaborating here
in driving these social problems,
we can break this down,
and we finally, I think,
can have solutions.
Thank you.
(Applause)